[MUSIC PLAYING]
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: In
Glenn Greenwald's book,
"No Place to Hide,
Edward Snowden, the NSA,
and the Surveillance
State," the journalist
writes of how
Snowden's morality was
influenced by his
consumption of video games.
He was inspired by his
experiences playing
as characters who were
often ordinary people, who
became heroes who prevailed
against powerful enemies
fighting for what they
believed in to right
the wrongs they
saw in the world.
Whether or not you
agree with the actions
that brought Edward
Snowden to infamy,
the fact that he was
influenced by video games
is fascinating, but should
perhaps be unsurprising.
We're used to books and
films that make us think.
Why not games?
I'm Jordan Erica Webber, a
video game critic for print,
radio, and television, and
the co-author of a new pop
philosophy book called,
"Ten Things Games
Can Teach Us About Life,
Philosophy, and Everything."
In this book, my
friend, colleague,
and fellow philosophy graduate,
Dan Griliopoulos and I
argue that video
games can help us
to think about a whole range
of philosophical topics,
from skepticism to personal
identity, to ethics.
I'm going to try and give you
a taste of our argument today.
Here is the requisite definition
of philosophy, a subject that
helps us to become
rational thinkers,
and is thus increasingly
important these days.
And in the interest
of spoiler warnings,
here is a list of games
I'm going to discuss.
Sorry.
[LAUGHS] "Mass Effect
3" tells the story
of Commander Shepard's
attempt to save
all sentient life in the
galaxy from annihilation
by giant synthetic organic
hybrids, called Reapers.
In one mission, she is tasked
with retrieving Admiral
Zaal'Korris vas Qwib-Qwib,
a high ranking member
of the quorian species,
named, as is traditional,
for his ship, the Qwib-Qwib,
who is needed for the war effort
that is currently under
attack by the robotic geth,
which of the blurry beings that
you can see in the background.
When you get to the former
quorian home world of Rannoch,
however, and manage to radio
through to Admiral Korris,
he begs you to rescue
his crew instead.
They've been separated from him.
And they're noncombatants.
They were never supposed to
find themselves fighting geth.
Stick to your original mission
by convincing Korris to give up
his location so that
you can rescue him
and his crew will die.
Allow Korris to sacrifice
himself for these civilians,
however.
And without his leadership,
several quorian ships
will abandon the
fleet, weakening
the strength of the forces
taking on the Reapers
and putting many
more lives at risk.
Each player's Commander
Shepard is different,
their appearance,
abilities, personality,
and choices customized.
What choice does your
Commander Shepard make and why?
What is her philosophy?
The question of whether
it's morally permissible
to sacrifice the
few to save the many
is such a popular trope
in all sorts of fiction
that you've probably
already heard
of the philosophical
version, which
asks whether you
would pull a lever
to divert a runaway train
so that it kills only one
person instead of five.
And then it escalates.
Would you push somebody off
a bridge to stop the train?
What if that person
was your mother?
This question, which came to be
known as the "trolley problem"
first appeared in a 1967 paper
by philosopher Philippa Foot
in a discussion of abortion.
Specifically, she was
exploring the doctrine
of double effect, a principle
by which it's sometimes
OK to cause harm as a
side effect of doing good,
but not as a means by which
to bring about that good.
You've probably
seen this at work
in comic books
and Marvel movies.
First, Foot proposed
a hypothetical riot
that was guaranteed to
have five casualties that
could be prevented
if a judge framed
and executed an innocent man.
And she compared this case to
the runaway train, guaranteed
to also killed five people
unless the driver switched
tracks to instead kill just one.
These scenarios are
mathematically similar,
both exchanging
one life for five.
But Foot suggests
that our intuitions
about the right course of
action differ in each case.
This kind of presentation of
an imagined scenario in order
to test intuitions
about the consequences
is known as a
"thought experiment."
The "Trolley Problem"
is an example
that is now often used
to test our intuitions
about utilitarianism, a
philosophical theory of ethics
by which the right action
is that which maximizes
the total utility,
which is often
substituted with happiness.
So a utilitarian ought to throw
their mother onto the track,
because that's a happier event
overall than the loss of five
other lives.
But after thinking through
this imagined scenario,
your intuitions might leave
you feeling otherwise.
Given the nature of the
subject, thought experiments
are crucial to the
study of philosophy.
Someone yesterday told me to put
pictures of puppies or kittens
in the talk, so--
[LAUGHTER]
--hopefully this qualifies.
Video games also
often present imagined
scenarios that test the player.
They can set us up
in immersive worlds
where certain
conditions are true,
like a world in which there's
a floating city and people can
travel between dimensions,
and then either show us
how the simulation plays out
or allow us to act according
to our beliefs and goals.
Here is where video
games have an advantage
over other thoughtful
media, like books and films.
They're interactive.
They have what academics
call the execution element.
You can execute the experiment.
In "Heavy Rain," you play
as unfortunate father
of two, Ethan Mars, who has
lost one son in an accident
and is now at risk
of losing his seconds
to a murderous kidnapper.
This kidnapper subjects
Ethan to a series of tests,
rewarding him for each
one successfully completed
with a clue to his
son's location.
In one test, Ethan is instructed
to cut off his own finger.
If any of you are
parents, you might
say that you would be
able to mutilate yourself
for the sake of your child.
But in "Heavy
Rain," you actually
have to press the
series of buttons
that brings your
chosen tool down
upon a close up view of
Ethan's little finger
and keep pressing
until the job is done.
This execution element
makes more of a difference
than you might think.
My co-author, Dan, is
a sworn utilitarian,
that is, someone who believes
that the right action to take
is that which maximizes
overall utility or happiness.
But when he played Pippin Barr's
game version of the "Trolley
Problem," he was only able to
act according to his philosophy
until the game asked him to
label the potential sacrifice
of somebody he loved.
He chose his infant
daughter and found
that even though the
stick person on screen
clearly wasn't her, he
couldn't push the button that
would switch the tracks.
Thought experiments are
often used in philosophy
because the problems
being considered
couldn't be tested in real
life, whether for practical or
ethical reasons.
But immersive video games
feel closer to reality
than the abstract
discussions you might
have in a philosophy classroom.
There's even science
to back this up.
A team of researches,
led by Indrajeet Patil,
found that participants
responded differently
to moral dilemmas, including
the "trolley problem," when
they were presented in an
interactive simulation as
opposed to just via text,
perhaps because, as they
discovered, the
game-type scenarios were
more emotionally arousing.
And there's something
so much more impactful
about watching the consequences
play out on screen, rather
than in your
imagination, especially
those that are the direct
result of your actions,
whether that's seeing a
stick person get run over
by a runaway train or a
rescued Admiral Korris try
in vain to contact
his doomed crew.
Brenda Romero is a
veteran video designer
who has recently been working
on a series of analog games,
called "The Mechanic
is the Message."
She knows that the
way games involve
the player can make
them feel far more
complicit than the reader of a
book or the watcher of a film.
In her analog game, "Train,"
for example, players
pack little people
into carriages,
according to the
instructions they're
given by the deck of cards.
And they only realize
what exactly they're
complicit in when they draw one
with a destination, Auschwitz.
Several well-known
games use twist-like
reveals to play with the special
relationship between the player
and the player character.
And this is another
way that video games
can be more philosophically
interesting than other media.
In "Spec Ops, The
Line," for instance,
you learn at the same time as
your character, Captain Walker,
that several of his experiences
throughout the game,
which you've witnessed along
with him, were hallucinations.
And hallucinations
can play a role
in the kinds of arguments made
by a philosophical skeptic.
Always pause for Descartes.
As the 17th century French
philosopher Rene Descartes
pointed out, "If we
know that in some cases
our senses give us
inaccurate information
about the actual state
of the world, then
perhaps we can never
know whether or not
to believe what we see."
Many of us will never
have experienced
vivid hallucinations
in real life.
But the special relationship
between player and player
character means that a game
like "Spec Ops, The Line"
helps us to imagine what it
might be like to not be able
to distinguish between those
experiences that give us
accurate information about the
world and those that don't.
It makes the thought
experiment that much clearer.
Perhaps the most famous
use of that relationship
between player and
player character
to trigger
philosophical thought is
in "BioShock" in which the
player and the protagonist
Jack both learn partway
through the game
that his actions have been
predetermined by a character
called Atlas' use of the trigger
phrase, "would you kindly."
Controlling Jack
while he carries out
these subconsciously
delivered instructions
feels no different from
controlling a character who
supposedly has free will.
And we can imagine that
the same is true for us.
Perhaps we too only
feel like we are
free to make our own decisions.
How would we know?
That's me being determined
to drink a sip of water.
In "Soma," you play
as a man called
Simon, who suffers brain damage
from a recent car accident.
At the beginning
of the game, you
have to make him
drink tracer fluid
and travel to a lab for
an experimental brain scan
procedure.
It's a first person
game, which means
that you watch from a
first person perspective,
as Simon settles into
the researcher's chair,
closes his eyes, and
reopens them in a research
base under the sea.
After a little
exploration, you soon
discover that more than
100 years have passed
and the body you are now
controlling is robotic.
It turns out that the researcher
was copying Simon's brain
states onto a computer.
And they've been uploaded
to this robotic body
under the sea, 100 years later.
This robot has all of Simon's
memories, beliefs, and desires.
It thinks like him.
Just the transition
from researcher's chair
to underwater base felt seamless
from the player's perspective,
so too did it seem to
Simon's psychology.
As far as this
robot is concerned,
he and the Simon that
suffered the car accident
are the same person.
Of course, this makes
a few assumptions
about the way our
minds think and work.
You have to accept a particular
view of the philosophy of mind
in order for this in-game
experience to make sense.
But that's the point
of thought experiments.
Creative Director
Thomas Grip wanted
to test player intuitions about
consciousness and humanity
and personal identity.
So he presented a world in
which you can copy and paste
everything we think
makes a person who
they are, and then tested
the player's intuitions
about the consequences.
One test comes when Simon
needs to be copied over
to yet another new sturdier body
so that he can travel deeper
under the sea.
After you've gone through that
same experience of switching
perspective from one body to
another, you and this new Simon
both realize at the
same time that the body
you were previously controlling
is still awake and still thinks
it's Simon.
The new sturdier Simon
you are now controlling,
which has all of the
same psychological states
as the previous
one, is distraught.
Two Simons, he says.
There can't be two Simons.
You're even offered
the opportunity
to drain the old
Simon's battery to solve
this philosophical problem.
And yet despite this
warning, some players
are still shocked at the ending
of the game in which you copy
and paste Simon's psychology one
last time so that he can escape
the research base, only to find
that this time, the player's
perspective is left with
the Simon still stranded
under the sea.
The thought experiment
has played out
to its inevitable conclusion.
"Soma" is an intentionally
philosophical game.
And there are others like
it, perhaps most famously,
"The Talos Principle."
But we can find philosophy in
other less obvious games too.
Perhaps it's unfair to the
developers at Nintendo,
but I doubt they were
thinking about Descartes when
they made "The Legend of.
Zelda Spirit Tracks."
Nevertheless, this game in which
the long suffering Princess
Zelda's nonphysical
spirit is separated
from her physical
body supports a theory
of the philosophy of mind known
as Cartesian dualism, which
states that the mind
and body are made
of different kinds
of substances,
the body physical,
the mind immaterial.
In fact, any game
that features ghosts
supports this
philosophical theory,
whether its creators
intended that or not.
One of my favorite examples
of presumably unintentional
philosophy in a video
game is a DS game,
called "Ghost Trick,
Phantom Detective," which
has more than you might expect
to say about epistemology,
otherwise known as the
theory of knowledge.
In philosophy, the traditional
answer to the question,
what is knowledge, is that it
is a justified true belief,
that you know x
when you believe x.
You are justified
in believing x.
And x is true.
Video game developers
and philosophers
both love the number 3.
Proposed counter-examples
to this tripartite theory
of knowledge, which are
called Gettier cases,
after the American
philosopher Edmund Gettier,
offer scenarios in which someone
has a justified true belief,
but we wouldn't want
to call it knowledge.
In "Ghost Trick," you play
as an amnesiac phantom.
At the beginning of the
game he spots this corpse.
And he assumes, because he
can't see any other corpses,
that it's his.
Later on, he overhears
somebody who can also
see the corpse saying
the name, Sissel So he
infers that that's his name.
And as it turns
out, that's true.
The amnesiac ghost is,
in fact, called Sissel.
So the player character
has a justified true belief
that his name is Sissel.
But does he actually
know what his name is?
As the game progresses you
and Sissel both discover
that this corpse actually
belongs to a man named Yomiel,
who was engaged
to somebody called
Sissel, who killed
herself, which
is presumably why the other
witness said that name.
In a twist, the player
character is actually
the ghost of Yomiel's cat, whom
he named after his dead fiance.
[CHUCKLING]
So while Sissel had a justified
true belief about his own name,
we'd hesitate to
call it knowledge.
"Ghost Trick, Phantom
Detective" is one big Gettier
counter-example.
And finally,
there's "Fallout 4,"
a huge game in a
hugely popular series
set in an alternate reality
post-apocalyptic wasteland,
inhabited by super mutants and,
importantly for my argument,
artificial beings
that are almost
indistinguishable from humans.
One of your biggest
decisions in this game
is philosophical, as you
choose which of three factions
to side with,
based on your views
on whether these
artificial Synths can
be considered to have minds.
One faction, The
Railroad, believes
that the Synths
should be treated
like people, along with all
the rights that entails.
They asked you to help the
Synths to gain that freedom.
The Institutes, which is
kind of like the Google
of the post-apocalyptic
wasteland, created the Synths.
They view them as tools that
they can reclaim and reprogram
with your help.
And the quasi-religious
Brotherhood of Steel
believe the Synths
to be abominations
that should be destroyed.
One member of this faction
actually is a Synth himself,
but doesn't know it.
And if he finds out, he
insists that you execute him.
"Fallout 4" has many quests and
many choices for the player.
But you cannot complete the
game without siding with one
of these factions.
And whether you
realize it or not at
the time, that
decision depends on
philosophical considerations.
After studying the philosophy
of mind at university,
I thought myself
a functionalist,
someone who thinks that
whatever functions like a mind
is one, even if it doesn't
look anything like a human.
But in "Fallout
4," I found myself
siding with The Institute.
Just as Pippin Barr's
"Trolley Problem"
challenged my co-author
Dan's philosophy,
this big-budget action
game challenged mine.
Video games are many things.
But perhaps the creator of
the "Civilization" series,
Sid Meier put it best
when he characterized them
as "a series of
interesting decisions."
And I think the most interesting
decisions are philosophical.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you very much.
We do have time for questions.
I can start with one.
So I was wondering when
there's so much video games can
teach us, I don't know if--
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: 10.
There are 10 things.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
But 10 very deep things.
So are they subject at schools?
Or should they be?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER:
Video game, I think so.
I mean, so here's the problem.
Philosophy isn't really
taught at schools,
and it definitely should be.
Like in France, it's compulsory.
But here, it's not.
But I have friends
who are campaigning
to make it compulsory.
But if it is made
compulsory-- you know,
we watched "The Matrix"
in my university course.
I don't see why we
can't play a video game.
I mean, obviously
there are problems
with accessibility and stuff.
It's much easier to sit a bunch
of kids in a room with a movie
than it is to be, like, we're
all going to play a video game.
Do you all have a PlayStation 4?
But if it's
possible, then, yeah.
I think so.
I don't see why not.
AUDIENCE: You say
what distinguishes
a video game from a
thought experiment
is that you have this
execution engine.
But on the other hand, I can
think of a number of times
where while playing
a video game,
I did something that's
completely contradictory
to, like, what I
would do in real life.
So how do you see
those two things?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER:
Right, but when
you're doing a
thought experiment
and you're imagining
what you would do,
it's not necessarily what you
would actually do in real life.
And you think through all
of the different choices.
And that's the thing
people do in video games.
They save.
And then they reload.
And they play through
all the different choices
to see what happens.
It's not necessarily
that you have
to make the choice that lines
up with your philosophy,
but that the fact
of making the choice
is philosophically interesting
and leads you to kind of think
about subjects more.
I think.
[LAUGHS] I love your scarf.
AUDIENCE: Many of
the examples you
gave looked a bit
more modern to my eye.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't know very
much about video games.
Do you have any examples
in your research
from what are some of the
earliest examples of philosophy
that was included
in video games?
I mean, I came of age in the
Atari 2600 era so that's more--
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: No way.
There's no way you're
old enough for that.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: No comment.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: [LAUGHS]
So my co-author Dan--
and he'll kill me for
saying this-- he's actually
10 years older than me.
So a lot of his games, which are
in the latter half of the book,
are older.
There's a lot of-- because
obviously, games are different
now than they were then, right?
So there's a lot of like
text-based RPG and stuff
where people got
quite into philosophy
because it's basically like
an interactive science fiction
novel.
Can I-- I don't if this is--
I mean, it's mine.
[LAUGHTER]
The guy who wrote
the foreword, we
got Chris Avellone
to write the forward.
I don't know if
you've heard of him.
But he wrote like a
lot of the old RPGs.
And some of the stuff he worked
on is pretty philosophical.
I can't think of any names
off the top of my head.
But there is a handy index.
If you look in your copy of "Ten
Things Video Games Can Teach
Us," we, painstaking
process, we went through
and listed all of the
games that are mentioned.
So if you look at the
index and you're like,
oh, that game takes my fancy.
I wonder what's
philosophical about that?
You can just go to the
right page and find out.
But, yeah, I'm quite young.
So all of mine are quite modern.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Which game affected you
the most while playing.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Oh, so
while playing it, "Soma,"
the one that I--
the underwater one,
because that was just--
I mean, because I thought it
was just like a generic horror
game.
And I hated it when
I first started
playing it because there's
all these monsters in it.
But as I played it, I
was like, oh, right.
This is very intentionally
philosophical.
And each choice that you make
in it is a philosophical choice,
like very intentionally so.
"Fallout 4" was the
one that afterwards, I
was like, wait, hold on.
What have I done?
When I was thinking about
it was the one that I guess,
yeah, affected me in hindsight.
But "Soma" was the one
while I was playing it,
and that's the one we always
recommend people play.
Oh, we're going to--
AUDIENCE: Obviously,
with a lot of games,
there's a kind of a limited
set of choices you can make.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Obviously, it's
just a restriction of gaming.
But do you think that matters
that you could often only get,
say, two choices?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: No,
I think it's a good thing.
So the thing about thought
experiments in a classroom
is that philosophers are
contradictory people.
When you get a load
of philosophy students
in a classroom and
you say, here's
the thought experiment,
choice A or choice B?
They will always try to
go for choice C. It's
like some Batman kind of thing.
But with a video game,
it's programmed, right?
Like unless you are very
smart and you can mod it,
you can only make
choice A or choice
B. There's nothing
else you can do.
The game won't let you.
So I think restrictions
are a good thing.
But obviously, if
you want to explore
more open kind of stuff,
then, yeah, games like that
are harder to make.
But they do exist.
People are trying to
make more open games.
And a lot of the older ones,
you know, the text-based stuff,
there's a lot more
choice in those ones,
because it's cheaper.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
First of all,
what's the obsession
of philosophers with trains?
[LAUGHTER]
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's a
rather silly question.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER:
And same kind of people
maybe, who played with.
I played with a lot of train
sets when I was a child.
So--
AUDIENCE: Who
doesn't love trains?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER:
--that's probably
why I've ended up
being a philosopher who
plays a lot of video games.
AUDIENCE: The more
serious question,
seems that video games and
these philosophic questions
are a great way of gathering
statistical data on how people
react and how comfortable people
are to each and every choice
they make.
Is there any sort of
study, statistical study
on this, and probably,
to take a look
at how people from
different backgrounds
react differently
to different choices
or how comfortable
they are with them?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: That
would be fascinating.
Hopefully, a load of
psychologists who read my book
will start doing
that kind of work.
There is "The
Walking Dead" games.
Like, they measure all of the
choices that players make.
So they can tell you what the
end of the game, 97% of players
did this.
Why did you do this one?
What's wrong with you?
But they don't-- I don't think
they've really looked into it
any more deeply than just
giving you the numbers.
But hopefully, it
will happen in future.
AUDIENCE: So what
do you think it
is that makes these
choices in games
compelling and interesting,
because like obviously, you
know, immersion and
like photorealism helps.
But in something like,
you know, "Battlefield,"
you could choose to not shoot
the other soldier, right?
But like, no one does that.
And there are a lot of older
text-based games even that
have interesting choices.
So I guess are there-- like,
what sort of factors do you
think makes these choices--
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER:
Yeah, I don't really
think photorealism has
a lot to do with it.
I think it's just
the fact that you
have agency, which is the thing
people love about games, right?
It's the fact that you
can actually do stuff.
So, yeah, like the
old text-based games,
it's the fiction, right?
And that's why people love
novels and movies and stuff.
So that's what involves people.
It's the story.
And then it's just
the extra element
of the agency that makes them
slightly more compelling,
I would argue, if
they're good examples.
The problem is that the
majority of video games are bad.
[LAUGHS] So we're
not quite there yet.
But as they get better,
I think it will improve.
AUDIENCE: I know this
sounds a little bit greedy,
but I have three questions.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: No,
that's No, that's fine.
We've got time.
AUDIENCE: You seem
pretty good with numbers.
So have you ever tracked
like how much hour you
spend on the game?
And do you ever go back
and say, this time, I
choose A. How about the
next time I play it,
I choose B. But then with
all the heavy philosophy,
do you ever bring that
anger and frustration
into your real life?
And if you have to make all
series of different question,
like how do you deal with that?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: OK.
AUDIENCE: I mean, if you're
really into the games
and think like that?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Was that
all three questions in one?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Sort of a
series of question.
You imagine this is a game.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Yeah, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
I'm the hero.
Got it.
OK, so your first question,
you said I'm good with numbers.
Is that because I found
10 things that are
good about video games?
[LAUGHTER]
I haven't been good with
numbers for a long time.
So do I track the choices
that I make and do I go back
and try make different ones?
Is that what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: And how long
does it take, generally,
for you to go
through the question?
And I would imagine some
of the hard question,
if I don't want
to make a choice,
do people abandon this game?
Like, I can't play with anymore.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Oh, yeah.
No, people definitely
abandoned games
because they don't want
to make the choice.
And then people abandon games
for all sorts of reasons.
But, yeah, there are some
games that ask things of you.
So that game, "Train," people
walk away from that game
as soon as they realize
what they're doing.
But how long does
it take to go back?
It really depends on the game.
So the thing about "Soma," for
instance, very philosophically
interesting game, but
what do you do in it
doesn't actually
change what happens.
It's just about how
you feel about it.
So whether or not you kill
the previous Simon or not,
you still carry on
with the game the same
as you would have done.
It's just kind of
pressing that button
to drain his battery to
get rid of the problem
that there are now two of you.
How does that make you feel
is kind of what's important.
With a game like
"Fallout," I tell myself
I'm going to replay them.
And then I never do.
With a game like--
OK, so "Mass Effect,"
in that, so the game
will actually come
on to Shepard.
You can actually choose to
play as a man in that game
if you really want to.
And when I replay "Mass
Effect" to try and do
the bad choices to see what
happens, I play as a man
because it--
[LAUGHTER]
--because it feels
more realistic to me.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, my male Commander Shepard
is not a very nice person.
He sleeps around.
He picks all the
renegade options.
But I haven't finished a run
through of all those games
as him.
And that's one of
my favorite games.
I just don't have time.
Was that everything?
Oh, great.
[LAUGHS] I am good with numbers.
AUDIENCE: I'm getting curious
about this game-making process.
So you said that they are
intentionally philosophical,
some of the games.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Mm, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Now how far they go?
They look at papers
on the philosophy?
I mean, you know, there
must be philosophy journals.
Would they go beyond that?
They look at the neuroscience?
Do they put people
under the scanner?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER:
[CHUCKLES] Oh, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: How far does that go?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: That would
be a good story, wouldn't it?
I'll have to find out.
I don't know about
philosophers putting people
under scanners and things.
But I do know that
Thomas Grip, who
was the creative
director of "Soma,"
he read a bunch of philosophy.
Like, I interviewed
him for the book
and he wouldn't stop talking
about all the philosophy
that he'd read.
He recommended me
a load of books
and stuff that I haven't
read, because I'm a philosophy
graduate.
And I didn't do
any of the reading.
So yeah, they definitely
do actually look into it.
It depends on the writer.
So I know that the-- oh,
I'm going to be careful.
I'm being filmed, so I'm going
to be careful what I say.
Some game developers do more
of the research than others.
[LAUGHTER]
And I won't name any names.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I noticed
in when you have
the list of the 10 things--
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: --that virtue
ethics was in there, I think?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was just curious.
I haven't had a chance
to read the book yet.
Looking forward to it.
But--
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Good.
AUDIENCE: --what were
some interesting examples
of virtue ethics from games?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: OK.
So this wasn't in
my half of the book.
I did read his half of the book.
[LAUGHTER]
We proofread each other's.
Virtue ethics was in
one of these games
whose name I couldn't remember,
which I'm going to look at.
Oh, "Ultima," the
"Ultima" series.
They were basically
built on virtue ethics.
So the guy who calls himself
Lord British, Richard Garriott
who wrote the "Ultima" games,
Dan interviewed him about it.
And he basically-- he did like
a load of looking into virtues
in different fiction.
He looked at like you know
the 10 Commandments and all
the different religions.
And then he looked
at "The Wizard of Oz"
and was like, ah,
bravery, heart, brain.
And then he just made
his own list of virtues.
And apparently all
of those games,
none of which I've
played because I'm young,
sorry, [LAUGHS] yeah are
basically about virtue ethics.
And it's a really good chapter.
He interviewed a good
friend of mine, Angie Hobbs,
who's a philosopher
who does that stuff.
So it's a good one.
You should read it.
Sorry, I can't be more helpful.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked about some games
that are intentionally
philosophical
or they have some
philosophical choices in them.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: Do you think with
virtual reality or things
like that, just by
means of technology
we can maybe learn something
about any of the new games?
For example, I mean, I can
think of a simulation argument
or like solipsism or
something like that
that you can just learn
by immersing yourself
into these games
with virtual reality.
I don't know if you have
any thoughts on that.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER:
I'm glad you asked.
Chapter three, "Virtual
Reality, A Real Reality,"
is all about whether virtual
reality counts as a reality.
A philosopher called
David Chalmers
has taken-- he doesn't
play a lot of video games,
as far as I can tell.
But he's taken a real
interest in virtual reality.
And he has this really
interesting argument
that I interviewed him
about where he says,
virtual reality is--
it's not an illusion.
It's a reality that's just
made of different stuff.
It's not physical.
It's virtual.
And the simulation
argument is mentioned
in that chapter, and
also, in the chapter
on epistemology and skepticism.
The simulation argument is
referenced in a recent video
game, called "No Man's Sky" by
Hello Games, which my co-author
Dan actually worked on.
So he wrote the simulation
argument into that game.
So that's a good one to play.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So in your examples,
it seems like most of them,
most of the decisions
were like built
in the games as the
designers intended.
But in lots of massive
multiplayer games,
lots of the decisions
emerge form the player base.
And economies develop.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And lots of
choices, yeah, happen there.
Do you see some--
do have some
thoughts about that?
Can you observe some
philosophical decisions
that appear in those contexts?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Yeah.
I mean, I can't think of
any specific examples.
But you're right that
multiplayer spaces online are
fascinating social experiments.
A lot of the stuff-- oh,
the political philosophy
chapter in the book
that Dan wrote,
he talks about "EVE
Online," which obviously,
is a huge game where people
are behaving in really, really
interesting ways because
of the like framework
that they find themselves in.
So yeah.
I do think it's interesting
in a slightly different way,
because it's not-- you're
right that it's not
written into the game.
I mean, we can't
ethically do an experiment
where we put a load of
people in space or then go.
But in a video game,
you know, they're
putting themselves
in that virtual space
by their own volition.
And then you can just sit
back and watch what happens.
And the developers of "EVE"
are really good about that.
They don't really
have much of a hand.
They just kind of observe, which
I think is really interesting.
You're welcome.
Oh, no, a follow-up.
AUDIENCE: Actually,
a different question.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
a game designer.
And I'm really
interested in the way
that the context
of the game shifts
the player's perception--
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: --of these choices.
So I was just curious from
your own experience as a player
how you found that things like
having an imposed goal on you
as the player, or, say,
having your choices impact
like statistics in the game?
Like you make a
certain ethical choice,
but it also has
other implications
for like, say, what
skills your character gets
or their appearance.
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Mm.
"BioShock"--
AUDIENCE: Like, how
these other game elements
you found in your
experience have an effect
on the choices you make?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER:
Yeah, so you're
right that that's
a kind of element
that I didn't really
touch on in the talk.
So we're obviously
in quite early days
with philosophy and games.
But some developers
are going further.
So Pippin Barr's "Trolley
Problem" game, he
was thinking about what
kinds of people game players
are when he made that.
So that's why the
game is so minimal,
because he was trying
to see if you took away
the like glorious blood and
gore effects of someone getting
run over by a train,
would it affect
how willing people were
to just run them over
to see what happened?
Because you're right that just
the feeling of being in a game
can sometimes make people make
different kinds of decisions.
So like the fact that people
go back and play a game again
to see what the different
choices are, because that's
just what game players do,
he works around that by--
I, mean obviously, you
can work around this.
But he made it so
that it's stored.
It's like cookies, right?
It's tech.
[LAUGHTER]
So it knows when
you played the game.
And it supposedly won't
let you play again
to kind of get around the fact
that players like to repeat
choices and stuff like that.
So yeah, there are
people thinking about it.
We're just, yeah, early days.
Hopefully, my book will help.
SPEAKER: Any more questions?
JORDAN ERICA WEBBER: Whoo.
[LAUGHS]
SPEAKER: If not,
we can close here.
Again, thank you very
much, Erica Jordan Webber.
[APPLAUSE]